PREVIOUSLY ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,"
JOANIE TOUGHED IT OUT
IN THE DENTIST CHAIR...
WOW.
AND CAME AWAY
WITH SOMETHING TO SMILE ABOUT.
MY PLEASURE, MY PLEASURE.
WHILE DANIELLE HUNG ON
TO HER GAP TOOTH GRIN...
THE GAP, I-I LOVE THE GAP.
AND THE DARK SIDE
OF MODELING
CALLED FOR A SHOOT
FILLED WITH BEAUTY AND TEARS...
KEEP IT SAD.
BUT BROOKE COULDN'T
BRING EMOTION TO HER SHOOT.
FOR A GIRL WHO CRIES A LOT,
I THINK THAT COULD HAVE BEEN
A STRONGER PICTURE.
AND SHE WAS SENT HOME.
SIX GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
(laughs)
STOP.
(sighs)
I HAVE ONLY ONE PICTURE LEFT.
WHO IS
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL?
FURONDA.
THANK YOU FOR BELIEVING
IN ME.
(laughs)
JADE IS MY FAVORITE PERSON
IN THE HOUSE.
THAT ONE...
OR THIS ONE?
(laughs)
JADE AND NNENNA SEEMED LIKE
TWO OPPOSITE PEOPLE TO ME,
BUT AS I'VE BEEN
GETTING TO KNOW BOTH OF THEM,
I DO SEE A LOT OF SIMILARITIES.
I WOULD LIKE
TO WORK WITH JADE SOMEDAY.
AND I'D LIKE TO WORK
WITH NNENNA.
JADE AND I
HAVE FORMED A FRIENDSHIP
EVEN THOUGH IT IS A COMPETITION.
(laughs)
WE JUST SEE IT AS
"MAY THE BEST PERSON WIN."
THIS COMPETITION, FOR ME,
IS LOOKIN' UP.
WHOO.
MY PICTURES
ARE GETTIN' BETTER AND BETTER,
THE JUDGES ARE
TAKING NOTICE OF ME.
I WASN'T SURE
YOU WERE PHOTOGENIC,
AND AS THE WEEKS HAVE GONE ON,
YOU'VE JUST GROWN.
AND THAT IS WHAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR OFTEN
IN A TOP MODEL--
SOMEONE THAT DEVELOPS.
I'M BEGINNING
TO BE A FORERUNNER
IN THIS COMPETITION,
AND IT'S SETTING ME ON A PATH
TO WIN, WIN, WIN, WIN, WIN.
OOH, MY LEGS IS BURNIN',
MY JOINTS, MY HIPS.
THE COMPETITION
IS GETTING REALLY SERIOUS,
AND TYRA ASKED ME TO GET
THE GAP IN MY TEETH CLOSED.
EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
DO YOU REALLY THINK YOU CAN
HAVE A COVERGIRL CONTRACT
WITH THE GAP IN YOUR MOUTH?
YES, WHY NOT?
THIS IS ALL PEOPLE SEE.
IT'S EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
IT'S NOT MARKETABLE.
I DON'T WANNA GO HOME
BECAUSE I DIDN'T GET
THE GAP CLOSED.
I HAVE TO CHOOSE MY GAP
OR GOIN' HOME,
AND I'M AT THE BOTTOM RIGHT NOW.
I FEEL LIKE THAT IS
THE BIGGEST CHALLENGE
THAT HAS EVER FACED ME.
TYRA MAIL.
"HOW PRESSED ARE YOU TO WIN?
"FIND OUT IF YOU CAN
HANDLE THE STRESS.
TYRA."
♪♪♪
HI, I'M RACHEL McCALLISTER,
AND I'M A PARTNER
AND CO-FOUNDER
IN MPRM PUBLIC RELATIONS.
AT THE AGENCY, MY ROLE IS
TO HELP MEDIA-TRAIN OUR CLIENTS,
AND THAT MEANS HELPING THEM
TO DO A REALLY
EFFECTIVE INTERVIEW.
RACHEL McCALLISTER--
SHE'S GIVIN' US
THE DO'S AND DON'TS
OF DEALING WITH THE PRESS.
DON'T BE SURPRISED
IF SOMEBODY COMES UP TO YOU
AND SAYS, "OH, SO I HEAR
YOUR FATHER'S REALLY HORRIFIED
BY THE FACT THAT
YOU'RE DOING THIS SHOOT
WHERE YOU GOTTA
TAKE YOUR CLOTHES OFF.
WHAT YOU WANNA DO IS SAY,
"WELL, THAT'S AN AREA
THAT IS OF CONCERN TO HIM,
BUT HE'S REALLY SUPPORTIVE."
FOCUS ON THE POSITIVE.
YOU'RE GONNA BE ASKED
A LOT OF VERY TOUGH QUESTIONS
LIKE, "I HEAR YOUR BOYFRIEND
CAUGHT YOU WITH ANOTHER GUY."
(laughs)
WHAT WAS THAT ALL ABOUT?
LAST FRAME.
WORK, DAMN IT.
I-I THINK EVERYTHING
IS GONNA BE FINE.
OH, GOD.
I INADVERTENTLY
HIT THE JACKPOT.
HAVING NO CLUE THAT APPARENTLY,
THAT MUST HAVE HAPPENED.
THIS IS CLEARLY THE ONE QUESTION
YOU DIDN'T WANT ASKED.
YEAH.
KNOW THAT
IT'S GONNA BE ASKED.
THEY ALL SEEMED TO UNDERSTAND
WHAT I WAS SAYING.
OF COURSE, THE TRUTH
WILL BE IN THE CHALLENGE,
BECAUSE I'M NEVER GONNA BE
AS TOUGH AS A REPORTER.
TODAY I'VE SET UP AN INTERVIEW
WITH COLUMNIST GEORGE WAYNE.
GEORGE WILL BE JUDGING YOU
ON TWO ISSUES--
ONE ON HOW EFFECTIVELY
YOU ANSWER HIS QUESTIONS,
AND TWO, HOW WELL
YOU PRESENT YOURSELF.
GOOD LUCK.
MY NAME IS GEORGE WAYNE.
IF YOU'VE NEVER HEARD
OF MY NAME BEFORE THIS MOMENT,
YOU WON'T FORGET IT
BEFORE THE END OF THIS EVENING.
YOU READY?
YES.
WHAT MADE YOU CONSIDER
A CAREER IN MODELING?
DO YOU THINK
YOU PHOTOGRAPH VERY WELL?
YES.
EVEN THOUGH
I CAN PLAY WITH MY AGE,
I CAN PLAY WITH
MY VERSATILITY OF LOOKS.
WHEN I INTERVIEW CELEBRITIES,
I GO FOR THE JUGULAR
IN A GOOD WAY.
RELAX A LITTLE BIT.
YOU'RE A LITTLE STIFF.
SIT BACK.
WHAT'S WITH THE HEAD WRAP?
IT'S JUST THE JADE STYLE.
YOU LOOK LIKE
AN ARROGANT BITCH TO ME.
I'M SORRY?
DO YOU THINK
YOU'RE ANITA SIMONE?
THIS IS SOMETHING, GEORGE,
I'VE BEEN TRYING TO DEFEAT,
BECAUSE I'M JUST VERY
DOWN TO EARTH, I'M VERY COOL.
I'M AN EXOTIC
BIRACIAL BUTTERFLY.
(laughs)
EXOTIC BIRACIAL BUTTERFLY.
YES.
- INTERESTING.
- YES.
I AM NOT AFRAID TO ASK
THE TOUGH QUESTION.
IT'S MY JOB,
AND I THRIVE ON IT.
WHAT WOULD YOU CONSIDER
YOUR WORST ATTRIBUTE?
I'M VERY STUBBORN.
IT RUNS IN THE FAMILY.
I'M VERY,
VERY CANTANKEROUS.
SPELL THE WORD.
- "CANTANKEROUS"?
- YEAH.
I'M NOT EXACTLY SURE
HOW TO SPELL "CANTANKEROUS."
WOULD YOU GIVE UP
YOUR BOYFRIEND FOR YOUR CAREER?
IN MY OPINION,
I FEEL LIKE IT WOULDN'T
BE ALL OR NOTHING FOR ME
JUST BECAUSE I FEEL A REAL
STRENGTH IN THAT RELATIONSHIP.
UNDO YOUR HAIR.
LET ME SEE.
- GIVE ME A LITTLE...
- (laughs)
LIKE, AAH.
LET ME SEE IF YOU HAVE
ANY SEXINESS TO YOU.
I'M NOT SEXY?
NOT REALLY.
IS MY HAIR PRETTY, THOUGH?
PRETTY HAIR.
YOU THINK
YOU'RE THE QUEEN OF SHEBA?
NO, I'VE NEVER BEEN TO SHEBA.
I'VE NEVER BEEN TO SHEBA.
DO YOU THINK SO?
YEAH,
YOU'RE A SHEBA LIONESS.
(imitates roaring)
ROAR FOR ME.
WHAT WOULD YOU CONSIDER
THE MOST AMAZING
PHYSICAL ASSET THAT YOU POSSESS?
MY SMILE.
MOST PEOPLE
RECOGNIZE MY SMILE.
I'M DUMBSTRUCK.
YOU'RE DUMBSTRUCK?
I'M SURE YOU GET THAT
ALL THE TIME.
WHY IS THAT?
YOU'RE A GAZELLE.
WHY DO YOU SAY THAT?
YOU'RE A SNOB.
REALLY?
MM.
I DON'T THINK SO.
JUST BY YOUR REACTION,
I CAN TELL.
NO, I'M NOT SNOBBISH.
WHAT IS THE ONE THING
YOU WANT THE WORLD
TO KNOW ABOUT YOU?
I HAVE A BIG FAMILY
IN AFRICA,
AND I THINK HAVING FAIR TRADE
IN AFRICA WOULD HELP THEM.
YOU SOUND LIKE
A MISS WORLD CONTESTANT.
NO, IT'S NOT LIKE I HAVE--
THIS IS NOT
MISS UNIVERSE PAGEANT.
NNENNA IS A BIG PRESENCE,
VERY SMART.
YOU CAN TELL THAT
SHE IS A VERY COMPLEX CREATURE.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
IT'S NICE TO MEET YOU.
I WAS HERE TO JUDGE
ON A CERTAIN LEVEL
THE GRACE, THE CHARACTER,
THE PRESENCE OF EACH GIRL.
GIRLS, I WANT
TO THANK ALL OF YOU.
WHAT I WANNA DO
IS TELL YOU WHAT I LIKED
AND WHAT WE PROBABLY COULD
WORK ON A LITTLE BIT.
SO I'LL START WITH FURONDA.
YOU HANDLED A TOUGH SESSION,
AS IT WERE, AND I THOUGHT
YOU DID VERY WELL.
JOANIE, OF ALL THE GIRLS TODAY,
YOU WERE THE TRUEST.
I THINK YOU'RE SPECIAL.
DANIELLE, I THINK
YOU HAVE A GREAT PRESENCE,
BUT YOU NEED TO,
UH, IMPROVE YOUR SPEECH.
SARA, SMART GIRL,
BUT I'M NOT REALLY SURE
IF THIS IS REALLY
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
I HAVE TO FIGURE OUT
WHAT I'M DOING
THAT IS MAKING PEOPLE THINK
I DON'T REALLY WANT THIS,
AND I HAVE TO
FIX THAT IMMEDIATELY.
NNENNA, YOU HANDLED YOURSELF
WELL UNDER PRESSURE.
SOMETIMES I THINK
YOU'RE A LITTLE SNOBBY,
BUT, UH, YOU'RE QUITE GOOD.
JADE, GIVE ME
THOSE DAGGER EYES.
RELAX A LITTLE BIT.
DON'T TAKE ON
YOUR INTERVIEWEE.
A LITTLE HUMILITY
GOES A LONG WAY.
ANYWAY, I CAN ONLY CHOOSE
ONE GIRL.
IT'S REALLY TOUGH FOR ME,
BUT I'M GONNA GO WITH NNENNA.
(applause)
THANK YOU.
YOU GAVE A GREAT INTERVIEW,
AND I THINK YOU HAVE
IMMENSE POTENTIAL TO BE PROBABLY
THE BEST TOP MODEL EVER.
I THINK NNENNA'S
HITTING THE NAIL ON THE HEAD
PRETTY CONSISTENTLY.
I'M JUST GONNA
HAVE TO WORK HARDER
TO TRY TO BEAT NNENNA OUT
AT THE NEXT ONE.
YOU'LL BE GETTIN'
A SPA TREATMENT,
ALL EXPENSES PAID,
AND YOU GET TO CHOOSE
ONE OF THESE LOVELY LADIES
TO GO WITH.
JADE.
JADE AND NNENNA
HAVE WON SIX TIMES.
YOU JUST GET SICK
OF THEM WINNING.
AND THE REST OF YOU GIRLS
ARE GOING TO HAVE TO CATER
TO THESE LOVELY WINNERS.
THE GIRLS
HAVE A RIGHT TO BE MAD
THAT THEY KEEP NOT WINNIN',
BUT THIS IS A COMPETITION.
WHAT DO YOU EXPECT?
SOMEBODY'S GOTTA WIN,
AND SOMEBODY'S GOTTA LOSE.
I REALLY ENJOYED
MEETING ALL OF YOU,
AND YOU ALL HAVE SOMETHING
REALLY SPECIAL.
NICE TO MEET YOU, TOO.
I THINK THAT DANIELLE
NOW SEES HER GAP AS SOMETHING
THAT MAKES HER UNIQUE,
BECAUSE IT'S KIND OF SIGNATURE.
I'M TRYING TO REMAIN CALM--
DON'T TRIP.
YOU KNOW,
THIS IS THE BUSINESS.
JUST, YOU KNOW, GO ALONG
WITH IT, BUT I'M DISTURBED.
(phone rings)
HEY, MAMA.
I HAD TO GO HOME
AND CALL MAMA.
SHE IS MY STRENGTH.
WHEN I'M TRIPPIN', I ALWAYS KNOW
THAT I CAN CALL MY MOM.
IT'S TAKEN ME SO LONG TO BECOME
COMFORTABLE WITH MY GAP,
AND, SO, I'M PISSED OFF,
BECAUSE IT'S EITHER,
"YOU CLOSE
YOUR GAP OR YOU GO HOME."
Uh-huh.
SO YOU'RE NOT READY
TO CUT YOUR HAIR?
NO.
YOU JUST GOTTA LEAVE MY SET,
OKAY?
I HAD TO THINK ABOUT IT.
IT'S LIKE, OKAY, DO I LIKE MY
GAP MORE THAN I LIKE MODELING?
♪♪♪
MISS TYRA BANKS WANTED ME
TO GO BACK TO THE DENTIST
TO GET MY GAP CLOSED.
DO I DO IT
OR DO I NOT DO IT?
SO WE TALKED A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT THE--ABOUT THE GAP
BETWEEN YOUR TWO FRONT TEETH.
I MAY NOT BE ABLE
TO SHUT IT COMPLETELY,
BUT LET'S SEE IF WE CAN REACH
A HAPPY MEDIUM
AND GET SOMETHING
THAT STILL LOOKS NATURAL.
I DON'T WANNA BE, LIKE,
ASHAMED TO SMILE, BECAUSE--
NO, NO,
WELL, THAT'S NOT GONNA WORK
FOR YOUR LINE OF WORK ANYWAY.
- OKAY.
- WE WANNA MAKE YOU HAPPY.
YOU KNOW, AS TYRA WOULD SAY,
WE WANT YOU TO LOOK FIERCE.
RIGHT.
I DO RESPECT TYRA'S OPINION.
I DO TAKE HEED TO EVERYTHING
THAT SHE'S SAYIN'.
SO I GOTTA SUCK IT UP,
I GOTTA BITE MY LIP,
AND I GOTTA GET MY GAP CLOSED,
AS MUCH AS I DON'T WANT TO.
♪♪♪
THAT'S US BEFORE THERE.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GOT NOW.
(gasps)
OH, MY GOODNESS.
SO WE DIDN'T
CLOSE IT DOWN ALL THE WAY.
IF WE CLOSE IT DOWN
ALL THE WAY,
IT WILL MAKE THEM LOOK, UH...
LIKE CHEATING.
ARE YOU HAPPY
WITH THE WAY IT LOOKS?
YEAH, YOU DID A GOOD JOB.
I LIKE IT, KIND OF.
IT'S DIFFERENT.
IT'S GONNA TAKE ME
SOME GETTIN' USED TO.
I'M GONNA BE IN THE MIRROR
ALL NIGHT TONIGHT.
IT'S SO WEIRD
HAVING THE GAP CLOSED.
I MEAN, IT'S BEEN A PART OF ME,
LIKE, ALL MY LIFE,
AND NOW IT'S NOT THERE ANYMORE,
BUT, YOU KNOW, I'M GONNA
KEEP A SMILE ON MY FACE
AND KEEP GOIN'.
♪♪♪
THERE WAS A STUPID CHALLENGE.
HE DIDN'T GET THE IMPRESSION
THAT I--THIS IS, LIKE,
REALLY WHAT I WANNA BE DOING.
I THINK THE FACT THAT
I WAS KIND OF FOUND IN A MALL
HAS WORKED AGAINST ME ALMOST.
SO SARA, WE FOUND YOU
IN A MALL AND CHASED YOU DOWN.
I'VE ALWAYS WONDERED
ABOUT MODELING.
I'VE BEEN APPROACHED
IN THE PAST,
BUT I'VE ALWAYS
BEEN AN ATHLETE.
MY DESIRE HAS BEEN QUESTIONED,
LIKE, NUMEROUS TIMES,
AND I JUST--
I HATE HEARING THAT.
I mean, you just have to
go the extra mile with that,
you know?
I DON'T WANT PEOPLE TO THINK
THAT I DON'T WANNA BE HERE.
I REALLY NEED TO SHOW
HOW MUCH I DO WANT IT.
♪♪♪
WE WERE SUPPOSED
TO BE HAVING DINNER,
AND WE WALK INTO THIS ROOM,
AND IT LOOKS VERY CULTURAL.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, WE HEAR
SOME HIGH HEELS CLICKING.
HI, GIRLS.
I'M TY-RA.
(screaming)
IN COMES A FAKE
DRAG QUEEN VERSION OF TYRA.
(laughs)
I JUST WANTED TO COME IN
AND HAVE A LITTLE CHIT-CHAT
WITH YOU GIRLS.
AND IT'S SUTAN,
OUR MAKEUP ARTIST.
EVERY MORNING WHEN I WAKE UP,
LITTLE WOODLAND ANIMALS
COME TO GREET ME.
(laughs)
- I'M TY-RA.
- TY-RA.
I'M TY-RA.
CAN'T YOU TELL?
LOOK, I GOT THE OUTFIT ON.
I'M TYRA, HEY, HONEY.
YOU KNOW WHAT?
(screams)
I AM SO TIRED
OF YOU IMPERSONATING ME.
AM I TY-RA?
I'M TY-RA.
- TYRA.
- THANK YOU.
- I'M TY-RA.
- I AM TYRA.
- I AM TY-RA.
- I AM TY. TY TY, BABY.
- I'M TY.
- YOU KNOW WHAT?
I THINK THE ONLY WAY WE'RE GONNA
BE ABLE TO SETTLE THIS
IS TO GO TO THAILAND!
(screaming)
A COUPLE MINUTES AGO,
I WAS DEPRESSED ABOUT THE GAP.
I'M LIKE,
"FORGET THE GAP, SUCKA.
I'M GOIN' TO THAILAND."
THAILAND HAS
A WHOLE BUNCH OF FASHION
THAT YOU WOULD NOT BELIEVE.
THEY HAVE THAI FASHION WEEK.
IT'S CALLED
"EL BANGKOK FASHION WEEK,"
AND THE NEXT TIME I SEE YOU
IS GOING TO BE IN THAILAND.
SO I'LL SEE YOU LATER.
(screaming)
I'LL SEE YOU LATER!
I DON'T KNOW IF THAILAND
IS READY FOR FURONDA YET.
THEY'D BETTER BRACE
THEMSELVES.
I'VE ONLY BEEN TO CANADA.
THAT'S IT.
♪♪♪
WE ARE GOING TO THAILAND!
WHAT?!
THIS IS YOU.
YES.
MOVIN' OUT OF OUR HOUSE
IN L.A. IS BITTERSWEET.
SO MANY MEMORIES HERE--
THE ARGUMENTS WE HAD,
THE MAKE-UPS.
NOW THAT
IT'S ONLY DOWN TO SIX,
YOU REALLY DON'T KNOW NOW
WHAT COULD BE
THE DECIDING FACTOR.
IT'S REALLY A TIME
YOU REALLY HAVE TO STEP IT UP.
OH.
BYE, HOUSE.
IT WAS NICE KNOWING YOU.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA BE IN
STORE WHEN WE GET TO THAILAND,
BUT I HAVE
HIGH EXPECTATIONS OF MYSELF,
AND I THINK OTHER PEOPLE HAVE
HIGH EXPECTATIONS OF ME, TOO.
NNENNA IS ONE
OF MY MAIN COMPETITORS,
SO I'M JUST GONNA
HAVE TO WORK HARDER
'CAUSE I WANNA WIN,
AND I DON'T WANT ANYBODY ELSE
TO WIN OVER ME.
♪♪♪
I CANNOT BELIEVE
I'M IN BANGKOK, THAILAND.
I CAN'T BELIEVE IT.
WE ARRIVED IN BANGKOK,
AND UP PULLS A PINK VAN.
♪♪♪
I'VE NEVER SEEN
ANYTHING LIKE THIS VAN BEFORE.
SO WE HOP INTO OUR NEW CAR
AND TAKE OFF TO THE UNKNOWN.
♪♪♪
SAWADEE...
SAWADEE KAH.
WE'RE TRYING TO MAKE
A GOOD IMPRESSION HERE
AND POSSIBLY WORK HERE
IN THE FUTURE.
SO, UM, IT'S VERY IMPORTANT
TO LEARN THEIR CULTURE.
WE LEARNED A BUNCH OF STUFF
ON THE PLANE.
HELLO...
SAWADEE KAH.
HOW MUCH?
HOW DO YOU SAY, "HOW MUCH?"
HOW MUCH IS...
TAU RAI?
HOW DO YOU SAY "TOO MUCH?"
TOO MUCH?
JUST SAY, "NO, THANK YOU."
I CANNOT WAIT TO SHOP,
BECAUSE I HAVE
ABOUT 3,000 BAHT,
AND I'M GONNA
SPEND IT ALL HERE.
(speaks Thai)
WHEN WE ARRIVED
AT OUR HOTEL,
WE ARE JUST BLOWN AWAY.
THIS IS WHERE WE'RE STAYIN'?
NO WAY.
MM.
IT TAKES YOUR BREATH AWAY
HOW BEAUTIFUL IT IS.
AH...
SAWADEE KAH.
OH, THANK YOU.
CHEERS, EVERYBODY.
CHEERS TO EVERYONE.
CHEERS.
WHOO!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
WHAT A SPECTACULAR HOTEL.
IT IS FIT FOR A KING,
BUT WE ARE QUEENS,
AND IT DEFINITELY
SUITS US TO A "T."
LOOK AT THIS.
LOOK IT--
JADE, YOU WEREN'T KIDDING.
THAT IS ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
OH, MY GOD.
LOOK IN HERE.
OH, YOU GUYS HAVE
A NICE BATHROOM.
SWEET.
LOOK AT THIS.
IT'S REAL, TOO.
"STOP, GO AWAY,
I'M LOST, HELP."
(laughs)
"GO AWAY."
WHAT KIND OF NONSENSE?
BEING A TOP MODEL,
YOU'RE GONNA TRAVEL THE WORLD.
I THINK THIS IS A GREAT TEST
FOR ALL OF US TO SEE
WHO CAN REALLY HANDLE
THE CULTURE SHOCK.
ARE YOU SURE?
(speaks Thai)
♪♪♪
WE ARRIVE AT THE DULAYA SPA
TO PAMPER JADE AND NNENNA.
NNENNA WON
THE INTERVIEW CHALLENGE.
I'M GONNA GO WITH NNENNA.
(applause)
SHE CHOSE JADE
TO JOIN IN HER SPA TREATMENT.
WELCOME TO DULAYA SPA.
WHO ARE THE LUCKY LADIES
WHO HAVE WON THE SPECIAL PRIZE?
OKAY, WELCOME, PLEASE.
SO FAR IN THE COMPETITION,
I'VE WON MOST OF THE CHALLENGES.
IT'S GOOD TO BE DOING WELL.
I'M NOT JUST ONE OF THE BUNCH.
I'M ACTUALLY DOIN' OUTSTANDIN'.
AND THE OTHER LADIES,
PLEASE COME FOLLOW ME, PLEASE.
FURONDA AND JOANIE
ARE GOING TO BE ASSISTING
WITH THE MASSAGES.
FOR THE FIRST, WE WILL TAKE
THE BODY SCRUB
FOR THE WINNER FIRST.
THEY'RE GONNA BE NAKED?
DANIELLE AND I ARE GOING
TO BE ASSISTING THE GIRLS
WITH THEIR BATHS.
OH, GOT IT.
I FEEL KINDA BAD, BECAUSE I
REALLY WAS NOT DOIN' MY JOB.
I STRAIGHT FAILED.
I COULD HAVE DONE A BETTER JOB,
BUT I'M EXHAUSTED RIGHT NOW.
(humming)
I AM TAKING THIS,
UH, RESPONSIBILITY SERIOUSLY
BECAUSE OF THE CULTURE HERE.
CAN YOU DEMONSTRATE
ON THIS LEG FOR ME?
SHOW ME.
I DON'T WORK WELL WITH BODIES
AND TOUCHIN' ON PEOPLE,
FEELIN' 'EM.
I DON'T DO WELL WITH THAT.
I'M A MODEL,
NOT A MASSEUSE.
♪♪♪
FURONDA WAS MASSAGING
NNENNA'S LEG WITH ONE FINGER.
HOW YOU GONNA MASSAGE OIL IN
WITH ONE FINGER?
DON'T THAT FEEL GOOD,
NNENNA?
I FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE SCRATCHIN' ME, FURONDA.
THIS IS MY MASSAGE.
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET.
I DON'T HAVE
AN ITCH, FURONDA.
(laughs)
STOP IT.
WE'RE IN A COUNTRY
WHERE RESPECT IS SO IMPORTANT,
AND WE GOTTA JUST
TOUGH IT OUT,
AND YOU HAVE TO DO YOUR BEST
NO MATTER WHAT.
YOU WANNA DO THESE?
JOANIE, YOU DON'T HAVE ANY KIDS
HERE, ESPECIALLY NOT ME.
I'M GROWN, OKAY?
DID YOU--DO YOU WANNA
TAKE OVER?
NO.
OKAY, WELL, GO BACK THERE
AND MIND YOUR OWN BUSINESS.
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT.
THANK YOU.
FURONDA
IS DOING HER OWN THING.
JUST NOT GIVING A RAT'S ASS
ABOUT IT, REALLY.
ANYTHING ELSE?
NO, THAT'S IT, THANK YOU.
CAN I GET MY TIP, NNENNA?
WHERE YOUR PURSE AT?
I'LL JUST GET IT OUT MYSELF.
OKAY.
I'M SO GLAD THAT'S BEHIND ME.
I CAN GO AND WASH MY FINGER
AND TRY TO...
(breathes deeply)
SNAP OUT OF IT.
CAN YOU TURN THE AIR OFF,
PLEASE?
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
TYRA MAIL.
"I KNOW IT'S TOUGH
BEING AROUND SO MANY GIRLS.
SO GET SOME TAIL.
TYRA."
I WISH.
(laughs)
WE GONNA BE AROUND GUYS?
NO, IT'S SOMETHING
WITH ANIMALS.
"GET SOME TAIL"?
WHAT IS TYRA BANKS
TALKING ABOUT, "GET SOME TAIL"?
I'M CURIOUS AS TO FIND OUT
WHAT KIND OF TAIL
WE GONNA BE GETTING.
WHAT IS IT GONNA BE?
♪♪♪
SO WE ARRIVE
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT,
AND WE SEE THESE WOMEN
AND THEY HAVE
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES,
AND THEY'RE JUST FLOATING
IN THIS CANAL.
JUST...
CHILLIN'.
SO HOW ARE YOU GUYS
THIS MORNING?
GREAT.
SO THIS IS OUR FIRST
PHOTO SHOOT IN THAILAND.
- ARE YOU GUYS PSYCHED?
- YEAH.
SO TODAY YOU GIRLS
ARE GONNA BE SHOOTING HERE
IN THE FAMOUS FLOATING MARKET
IN THAILAND.
THIS IS WHERE YOU CAN COME BUY
FRUITS AND VEGETABLES AND FISH.
AND TODAY YOU GIRLS ARE GONNA
BE THE CATCH OF THE DAY,
AS IF WE ARE FISHING YOU
OUT OF THIS WATERWAY.
BEHIND ME, YOU CAN SEE
THERE IS A BIG RIGGING
WHERE YOU GIRLS
ARE GONNA BE HOISTED UP
AND HUNG UPSIDE DOWN.
AND YOU'RE ACTUALLY
GONNA BE MERMAIDS,
SO IT'S GONNA BE A REALLY,
REALLY COOL SHOOT.
NOW TODAY'S SHOOT IS FOR
BANANA BOAT SUNTAN LOTION,
AND BANANA BOAT WANTS YOU
TO CELEBRATE THE SUN
WITH THEIR ANTI-BURN SYSTEM.
SINCE YOU'RE GONNA
BE OUTSIDE ALL DAY,
DON'T FORGET
TO PUT ON YOUR BANANA BOAT
BEFORE YOU
GET IN THE HARNESS.
YOUR PHOTOGRAPHER
TODAY IS NOOM.
NOOM, COME OVER HERE.
HE'S AN AMAZING
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER.
THESE ARE YOU
SIX VICTIMS TODAY.
YEAH, YEAH.
ALL RIGHT?
SO LET'S GO DO THE SHOOT.
LET'S GO!
♪♪♪
WE'RE GONNA BRING YOU SOME
LITTLE FISH AND SOME SEAWEED,
'CAUSE IF YOU WERE SCOOPED
OUT OF THE WATER,
THERE'D BE SOME FISH
IN THAT NET, TOO.
IS THAT FISH JUICE
THAT I JUST FELT?
I REALLY HOPE THERE ARE NOT
ANY PIRANHAS IN THERE,
'CAUSE WE HAVE DEAD FISH
ATTACHED TO US.
(groans)
IF A PIRANHA
START BITING ON MY NECK,
I'MA BE A MAD SISTER.
♪♪♪
(speaking Thai)
HOW'S IT SMELL, DANIELLE?
I JUST THREW UP IN MY MOUTH
A LITTLE BIT.
(laughter)
SO THE IDEA OF THE SHOOT
IS YOU'RE KINDA UPSIDE DOWN.
OKAY?
UGH!
FISH JUICE.
FISH JUICE?
WORK WITH IT, GIRL!
NOW POSE.
YES.
THAT'S A PRETTY ONE,
DANIELLE.
I LIKE HOW
YOU'RE USING YOUR HANDS.
I'M FEELING SO MUCH PAIN
RIGHT NOW.
THE HARNESS IS, LIKE,
GETTING TIGHTER,
SO MY UTERUS IS, UH, PROBABLY
FLAT AS A PANCAKE RIGHT NOW.
IS IT OKAY LIKE THAT?
CAN YOU REST THERE
OR DO YOU WANNA COME ON BACK?
I WANNA GET 'EM DONE.
LET'S GO.
OKAY, YOU GOT 15 MORE.
15?
A COUPLE TIMES, YOU KNOW,
I WAS, LIKE, "OH, MY GOD,
THIS HURTS SO BAD.
I WANNA QUIT."
CAN YOU DO IT?
SO I HAD TO KINDA GET MYSELF
TOGETHER AND SUCK IT UP.
I'M NOT A QUITTER,
SO I HAD TO KEEP GOING.
SHE GOES FROM THIS TO THIS...
AND SHE KNOWS HER ANGLES.
LIKE, NOTICE HOW
SHE ANGLES HER HEAD?
SHE KNOWS WHAT LOOKS PRETTY.
WHEN I PUT DANIELLE OUT THERE,
I FEEL LIKE A PROUD PAPA,
'CAUSE SHE KNOWS
WHAT SHE'S DOING.
OKAY, GOOD JOB, DANIELLE.
NEXT VICTIM.
NNENNA,
IF YOU PUSH ON YOUR HIPS,
IT'LL STRAIGHTEN YOU OUT
A LITTLE MORE.
DON'T HOLD ONTO THAT CORD
THOUGH,
'CAUSE WE'RE
RETOUCHING THAT OUT.
IT'S DIFFICULT BECAUSE WHEN
I PICTURE A MERMAID,
I PICTURE,
LIKE, LONG, NICE HAIR,
AND I DIDN'T HAVE
ANY HAIR EXTENSIONS,
SO I DON'T KNOW WHAT KIND OF
OF MERMAID I WOULD LOOK LIKE.
I NEED YOU TO BE REALLY FEMININE
ABOUT YOUR ARM MOVEMENTS.
CAN I GET A DIFFERENT
FACIAL EXPRESSION?
THERE YOU GO.
NNENNA STARTED AT THE TOP AND
JUST KIND OF COASTED FROM THERE,
BUT THIS COMPETITION
IS ABOUT IMPROVING,
AND I DON'T NECESSARILY THINK
NNENNA'S STILL IMPROVING AT ALL.
ARE YOU ALL RIGHT, NNENNA?
YEAH.
YOU HAVE TO JUST PUSH THROUGH
TEN MORE FRAMES,
AND THEN YOU'RE DONE.
THIS IS CUTTING OFF
MY CIRCULATION IN MY STOMACH.
IF YOU TWIST YOUR HIPS
TO CAMERA,
IT WON'T HURT AS MUCH,
TWIST.
THERE YOU GO.
I THINK WE ALL KINDA PUT
NNENNA UP ON THIS HIGH PEDESTAL,
BUT SHE DIDN'T DO AS WELL
AS I THOUGHT THAT SHE WOULD
IN THE PHOTO SHOOT.
CHIN DOWN A BIT.
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY, WE CAN PULL HER BACK.
WHOO!
PLEASE DON'T BREAK ON ME.
PRETTY, PRETTY, PRETTY.
OH, THAT'S SO PRETTY.
SINCE WHEN DID YOU LEARN
HOW TO MODEL?
WHEN DID YOU LEARN
HOW TO BECOME SOFT?
I'M LEARNING, JAY.
HUH?
I'M LISTENING, I'M WATCHING
AND I'M LEARNING.
OH.
OKAY.
FOR SOME REASON, I KEEP
ON LANDING IN THE BOTTOM TWO,
WHICH I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY.
BUT I KEEP COMING BACK,
AND I'M COMING BACK
WITH A VENGEANCE.
I'M COMING BACK STRONG.
NOW GIVE ME THAT SOFT FACE,
THAT LITTLE SMILE.
JADE WAS ALWAYS SO HARD.
NOW JADE KNOWS HOW
TO LOOK SOFT.
AND UPSIDE DOWN,
THAT'S REAL DIFFICULT.
GOOD JOB, JADE.
I'M IMPRESSED.
TRY AND GET A BIT OF A SMILE
IN THERE IF YOU CAN,
LIKE IT'S NOT 180 DEGREES
OUT HERE.
AND POINT YOUR HEAD DOWN,
KIND OF LIKE...
READY?
OH.
OKAY, ONE MORE.
WHEN YOU PUT YOUR HANDS JUST
OUT LIKE THAT, IT LOOKS LIKE
THEY'RE JUST HANGING THERE,
SO TRY AND BE
A LITTLE MORE GRACEFUL.
SARA LOOKED LIKE A SCARED GUPPY
HANGING IN A NET
FOR HER FIRST 20 FRAMES.
THAT'S BETTER, SARA.
THAT'S GOOD, SARA.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
AFTER SHE GOT IT TOGETHER,
SARA STARTED LOOKING LIKE
A MODEL.
ARCH ALL THE WAY DOWN
LIKE THAT.
LIKE, ALL THE WAY
YOU WERE GONNA HANG.
STRAIGHTEN YOUR LEGS.
HANG YOUR ARM
ALL THE WAY DOWN IF YOU CAN.
YES, YES, YES, YES!
BEAUTIFUL.
REALLY PRETTY AT THE END.
I'M TRYING TO LEARN
AND GET BETTER.
I JUST WANNA REALLY
SHOW MY DESIRE
AND SHOW THAT
I DO WANNA BE HERE.
OH, THAT'S REAL!
THIS IS SO TIGHT.
DOES IT HAVE TO BE LIKE THIS?
THIS IS A LOT OF STUFF
TO HAVE ON.
HI, JAY!
MR. JAY!
WHAT ARE WE DOING?
THE WATER'S STINKY,
THE FISH ARE NASTY
AND I'M JUST TRYING
TO GET MY SHOOT DONE
SO I CAN
GET BACK INTO THE TRAILER,
WHICH IS AIR-CONDITIONED.
READY?
I'VE BEEN
A LITTLE BIT TURNED OFF
BY FURONDA'S DIVA ATTITUDE.
YOU NEED TO GET OVER YOURSELF
IF YOU'RE GONNA BE IN THIS--
IN THIS SORT OF PROFESSION.
FURONDA, ARE YOU READY?
LET'S GO.
(speaks Thai)
KEEP CHANGING UP YOUR HANDS,
FURONDA.
THE PAIN IS SHOWING
ON YOUR FACE,
AND I NEED YOU
TO ERASE IT FROM YOUR FACE.
FURONDA
LOOKED LIKE FISH BAIT.
SHE WAS SHOWING THE PAIN
ALL OVER HER FACE.
PUT YOUR HANDS IN YOUR HAIR
IF YOU WANT.
THERE YOU GO.
MAKE IT PRETTY.
SOFT FACE.
LOOK SERENE.
LAST FRAME.
THERE YOU GO.
OKAY, WE CAN PULL HER BACK.
SHE'S DONE.
DO WE HAVE
OUR NEXT GIRL READY?
I OWN THAT ONE, AND I HAVE
THE ONE FOR FACES, TOO.
YOU DO?
WHEE!
HEY, JOANIE, TRY AND TWIST
YOUR HIPS TO CAMERA.
I FEEL LIKE I'M GONNA
THROW UP.
YOU FEEL LIKE
YOU'RE GONNA THROW UP?
I JUST DRANK A LOT OF COFFEE.
YOU JUST DRANK A LOT
OF COFFEE BEFORE YOU DID THIS?
IF YOU KNEW YOU WERE
GONNA BE INVERTED,
UPSIDE DOWN IN A HARNESS,
WHY WOULD YOU DRINK
A WHOLE CUP OF COFFEE?
NOW YOU CAN'T BE AWKWARD
WITH IT.
YOU HAVE TO JUST
EITHER GO FOR IT OR DON'T.
I'M GOOD.
WARM FACE.
YES, THERE YOU GO.
REACH YOUR RIGHT ARM
OVER YOUR HEAD IF YOU CAN.
YES.
MY BOOBS WERE FALLING OUT.
I WOULD BE EXTREMELY EMBARRASSED
IF THE BOOBS FELL OUT.
THIS IS OVEREXPOSURE
FOR MOST THAI WOMEN,
SO I DIDN'T WANNA
OFFEND ANYBODY.
THERE YOU GO.
PRETTY.
I LIKE THAT.
WHAT I LIKE IS THAT I DIDN'T SEE
THE PAIN IN YOUR FACE,
AND I SAW A NICE,
SOFT EXPRESSION.
THAT'S GOOD.
EVEN THOUGH JOANIE FELT LIKE
SHE WAS GONNA THROW UP,
SHE TURNED IT OUT.
SHE LOOKED GREAT.
GOOD JOB, JOANIE.
THANK YOU.
(cheering)
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL.
TYRA MAIL!
SHALL I READ IT?
I'LL READ IT.
"TOMORROW YOU WILL MEET
WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY FIVE WILL CONTINUE
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING...
(whispering)
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
(normal voice)
TO BE HONEST WITH YOU,
I REALLY DON'T KNOW
WHO'S THE MOST VULNERABLE,
'CAUSE IT ALWAYS CHANGES.
I HAVE NO IDEA AT THIS POINT.
WE NEED TO GO RIGHT NOW.
WE JUST GOT TO THE BEST PART.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT'S GONNA
HAPPEN AT ELIMINATION.
OVERALL,
I THINK MY SHOOT WENT WELL,
SO I'M NOT REALLY WORRIED.
I THINK THE WORLD WOULD BE
VERY UPSET IF WE LEAVE.
(chuckles)
THEY CAN'T GO.
THEY GOTTA BE HERE
TILL THE END.
♪♪♪
ALL RIGHTY, LADIES.
YIN DEE DTAAWN RAP.
SAWADEE KAH.
YES, WELCOME TO THAILAND.
ISN'T THIS BEAUTIFUL?
SO THERE'S SIX OF YOU
THAT STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT AT THE END OF THE NIGHT
THERE WILL ONLY BE FIVE
BECAUSE ONE OF YOU
MUST BE ELIMINATED.
LET'S START WITH THE PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT COMPANY,
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE
THAT WILL BE SHOT
BY A WORLD-RENOWNED
PHOTOGRAPHER, GILLES BENSIMON,
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND, OF COURSE,
YOU KNOW THE JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED FASHION
PHOTOGRAPHER NIGEL BARKER...
DIVA EXTRAORDINAIRE
MISS J. ALEXANDER.
SIX DOWN,
ONE MORE TO GO TONIGHT.
THE LOVELY TWIGGY,
FASHION ICON...
AND JATURONG.
JATURONG IS THE PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT PHOTOGRAPHED YOU.
SAWADEE KAH.
NOW AS A MODEL,
YOU NEED TO KNOW
HOW TO SELL YOURSELVES
ON THE SPOT.
SO FOR YOUR JUDGING TEST,
I WANT YOU TO SELL
YOUR PERSONA TO THE JUDGES.
YOU CAN BE CUTE,
YOU CAN BE QUIRKY,
YOU CAN BE PROVOCATIVE,
BUT MOST OF ALL,
YOU HAVE TO BE MEMORABLE.
AND, JOANIE, YOU'RE FIRST.
WELL, MY MOTTO IS, "LIFE IS A
TRACK MEET, NOT A MARATHON.
IT'S OVER QUICKER THAN
YOU CAN THINK,
SO YOU BETTER DO IT RIGHT
THE FIRST TIME."
MY LOOK IS A VERSATILE.
I CAN TRANSFORM MYSELF
INTO ALL DIFFERENT TYPES
OF ETHNIC BACKGROUNDS.
I COULD KINDA...
FIT CERTAIN MOLDS
THAT I REALLY WANNA BREAK
IN THE INDUSTRY.
I AM INTELLIGENT, AND I USE
THAT INTELLIGENCE TO, UM...
A SMILE IS A...
(ding)
UM, THE SWORD TO BEAUTY.
(hisses)
(crickets chirping)
I HAVE A OUTLASTING GAP.
IT'S MY SIGNATURE TRADEMARK.
YOU WON'T FORGET IT.
MY BODY
IS VERY "PROPORTION-ABLE."
I USE THAT INTELLIGENCE
IN ALL ASPECTS OF MY LIFE.
UM...
AND...
WHEN I DO SPEAK,
PEOPLE REALLY SEE
THE OTHER SIDE OF JADE.
BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL
IS MY DREAM TO HELP ME
BREAK INTO THE INDUSTRY,
BECAUSE AT MY AGE...
AND I WOULD WORK REALLY HARD
WITH THIS TITLE
AND MAKE THE BEST OF IT
MORE THAN ANYBODY ELSE HERE.
MY LONG, WAVY HAIR--
KIND OF LIKE
A LATINA TWIST TO IT.
IT CURLS WHEN IT GETS WET.
GOTTA LOVE THAT.
I THINK THAT INTELLIGENCE
MAKES ME EXTREMELY SEXY
AND MARKETABLE.
I'M JADE.
MY PERSONALITY IS THIS.
WHAT YOU SEE IS
WHAT YOU GET.
DON'T JUDGE A BOOK
BY ITS COVER.
AND THE MOST IMPORTANT THING
I WANT TO ACHIEVE
IS USE MY PUBLICITY AND WALK
INTO THE NIGERIAN EMBASSY...
OKAY.
AND THEY'LL RECOGNIZE ME
AND BE LIKE,
"THAT'S THE GIRL FROM
'AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL'!"
(exhales deeply)
THIS IS A WONDERFUL,
WONDERFUL SURREAL EXPERIENCE.
AND MY LONG LEGS--
GREAT FOR THE RUNWAY.
(ding)
(laughter)
IS THAT WHAT YOU WERE
LOOKING FOR?
(gong bongs)
♪♪♪
SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE,
AND WE'LL DETERMINE
WHICH OF YOU WILL BE ELIMINATED.
FIRST UP IS JOANIE.
I THOUGHT
YOU WERE A BIT BLAND.
JOANIE, YOU'VE GOTTA
DELIVER YOUR LINES,
NOT JUST SAY THEM.
A SMILE IS A...
THE SWORD TO BEAUTY.
IF YOU'RE GONNA SAY "SMILE,"
YOU GOTTA SMILE.
WELL, JOANIE,
WHAT I WAS UPSET ABOUT
IS THAT NOTHING IS ORIGINAL.
"LIFE IS A TRACK MEET,
NOT A MARATHON.
IT'S OVER QUICKER THAN
YOU CAN THINK."
YOU'LL BE KNOW AS, LIKE,
THE BUMPER STICKER MODEL.
A BUMPER STICKER MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, JOANIE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU WERE A MERMAID
THAT WAS CAUGHT,
AND IN DOING SO,
YOU WERE FLIPPED UPSIDE DOWN.
SO LET'S SEE YOUR BEST SHOT.
PRETTY.
THAT'S AMAZING.
YOU'D NEVER KNOW
FROM THAT CLOSE-UP THAT
YOU WERE HANGING UPSIDE DOWN.
JAY SAID, DESPITE WATCHING
THE OTHER GIRLS,
YOU DRANK COFFEE
RIGHT BEFORE YOUR SHOOT
AND FELT LIKE VOMITING
THROUGHOUT.
I THOUGHT I WAS GONNA LOSE IT
BUT I WAS OKAY.
JOANIE,
YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JOB.
BEAUTIFUL FILM,
RELAXED FACE.
I THOUGHT THE REASON
WHY YOU GOT NAUSEOUS
WAS BECAUSE
YOU WERE THE ONLY ONE
THAT REALLY FLIPPED
TOTALLY UPSIDE DOWN.
NOT IN THIS ONE,
BUT SHE HAD A LOT
WHERE SHE WAS TOTALLY VERTICAL.
YOU DID A REALLY GOOD JOB.
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS JADE.
I THINK YOU CONTRADICTED
YOURSELF 'CAUSE YOU SAID,
"WHAT YOU SEE
IS WHAT YOU GET."
THEN YOU SAID, "DON'T
JUDGE A BOOK BY ITS COVER."
(laughs)
IT DIDN'T REALLY MAKE SENSE,
AND I THOUGHT THE SAME THING.
"PROPORTION-ABLE."
IS THAT A WORD?
HEY, GIRL,
I'M YOUR BIGGEST FAN.
I FEEL STUCK ON JADE,
BUT I LOVE IT.
BUT WHAT CLUB
ARE YOU GOING TO TONIGHT?
THE EARRINGS,
THE HAIR THING...
TOO MUCH EYE MAKEUP
AND THAT HEAD SCARF,
IT MAKES YOU LOOK
20 YEARS OLDER THAN YOU ARE.
I THINK THE HEAD SCARF
WOULD WORK WITHOUT THE EARRINGS.
BUT THE TWO TOGETHER...
THAT'S BETTER.
IS THIS BETTER?
BUT I LIKED
YOUR PERFORMANCE.
I THOUGHT THAT
YOU STOOD OUT.
IN THE END, JADE,
MISSION ACCOMPLISHED.
MERCI.
ALL RIGHT, JADE,
YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU WERE A MERMAID.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THE BODY ANGLE
IS WONDERFUL.
AND IT'S
QUITE SENSUAL AS WELL,
WHICH I THINK A MERMAID
SHOULD BE.
SHE'S VERY INTERESTING.
SHE POSED VERY WELL
AND VERY GOOD.
IF YOU COME TO THAILAND,
YOU KNOW, I THINK SHE--
SHE COULD BE
THE TOP MODEL HERE.
KHAAWP KHOON KA.
UP NEXT IS NNENNA.
I THOUGHT YOUR SPEECH
WAS VERY MISS AMERICA'S
NEXT TOP MODEL.
USE MY PUBLICITY AND WALK
INTO THE NIGERIAN EMBASSY...
OKAY.
"THAT'S THE GIRL FROM
'AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL'!"
ON AND ON AND ON,
AND ON...
AND ON.
YOU KNOW, IT'S BORING.
I KEPT ON FEELING LIKE
YOU WERE FINISHED,
BUT YOU WEREN'T, LIKE,
FOUR OR FIVE TIMES.
I THOUGHT YOU SAID,
SELL YOURSELF, WHO YOU ARE.
YOU WERE TRYING TO SELL IT,
BUT WE DIDN'T BUY IT.
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU WERE A MERMAID.
IT LOOKS PRETTY,
BUT IT LOOKS LIKE
SHE'S HANGING THERE.
WHAT MAKES YOU A MERMAID?
I NEEDED TO TRANSFORM
MORE THAN THIS PICTURE SHOWS.
IT DOESN'T LOOK LIKE
A MERMAID, DOES IT?
AND I JUST WISH
MAYBE THE ARMS COULD'VE BEEN
JUST A LITTLE LESS THAT...
AND MORE...
NNENNA, AT THIS STAGE
OF THE COMPETITION,
YOU JUST REALLY NEED
TO BRING UP SOMETHING DIFFERENT.
NOT JUST
THE SAME OLD NNENNA.
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA,
YOU WERE THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
WELL DONE.
GEORGE WAYNE SAID THAT
YOUR PRESENCE IS VERY STRONG,
VERY SMART AND AWARE.
ON THE NEGATIVES,
HE THOUGHT YOU WERE
A LITTLE SNOBBY, NOT CHARMING.
(imitates Nnenna)
IT'S BETTER WHEN YOU SPEAK
LIKE THAT, YOU KNOW.
YOU SPEAK WITH ATTITUDE.
I AM AN AFRICAN QUEEN,
AND I KNOW BETTER.
I DON'T KNOW
WHERE HE GOT THAT FROM.
(normal voice)
YOU'RE MISUNDERSTOOD,
LIKE JADE IS SOMETIMES.
UP NEXT IS DANIELLE.
DANIELLE, FOR ME,
YOU'RE THE BEST.
I THOUGHT YOU HAD SPUNK,
PERSONALITY...
IT WAS YOU.
YOU SAID A COUPLE
OF GOOD THINGS
AND A COUPLE
OF REALLY FUNNY THINGS.
BUT YOU--YOU SOLD IT.
AND I LIKED THAT
YOU TALKED ABOUT THE GAP.
LET'S SEE IT.
IT'S KINDA THERE
BUT NOT REALLY. NICE.
I LIKE THE WAY
YOU RUBBED THAT IN, TOO.
"MY GAP IS WHAT MAKES ME
IMPORTANT."
ALL RIGHTY, DANIELLE,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WHERE YOU HAD TO HANG
UPSIDE DOWN AS A MERMAID.
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THERE'S NO STRAIN.
YEAH, NO STRAIN.
IT'S--IT'S EFFORTLESS.
ALL RIGHT, TO BE UPSIDE DOWN
AND SEXY, AND YOU DID THAT.
SHE LOOKED--SHE LOOKED GREAT,
YOU KNOW, IN FRONT OF THE--
THE CAMERA.
VERY ELEGANT, YOU KNOW.
YOU'VE DEFINITELY GOT
STRENGTH IN THE EYES.
IT'S AN ENDEARING,
POWERFUL SHOT.
UP NEXT IS SARA.
WELL, I STILL THINK
YOUR GREATEST ASSET IS YOUR--
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT VOICE.
BUT TO ACTUALLY SAY
TO A JOURNALIST,
"I'M INTELLIGENT," IS LIKE
WAVING A RED FLAG TO A BULL.
ALL RIGHTY, SARA,
SO YOU HAD A PHOTO SHOOT,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
I THINK YOUR FACE
LOOKS VERY PRETTY IN THIS.
I THINK THE ARMS
ARE A LITTLE AWKWARD.
YEAH,
THAT WAS MY COMMENT, TOO.
SHE LOOKED A BIT RAGGEDY
AROUND THE ARMS.
AND I THOUGHT,
LOOKING AT YOUR FILM,
WHEN YOUR FACE IS ON, SARA,
IT'S SO ON, BUT IT'S NOT ON
OFTEN IN YOUR FILM.
I'M NOTICING, LIKE,
A PATTERN OF THAT.
ALL RIGHTY,
THANK YOU, SARA.
LAST BUT NOT LEAST,
FURONDA.
YOU SEEMED
REALLY UNSURE TO ME.
I JUST DIDN'T KNOW
WHAT YOU WANTED.
YEAH, I WROTE DOWN,
"GOT VERY CONFUSED."
NOW WHAT INVITATION
DID YOU GET
THAT WE DIDN'T GET
FOR THIS PARTY TONIGHT?
'CAUSE YOU ARE SO...
(high-pitched voice)
DOLLED UP.
THAILAND.
IT'S A CELEBRATION.
IT IS A LITTLE TOO DRESSY,
FURONDA.
I DON'T THINK
YOU GOT THE JEAN MEMO.
ALL RIGHT, FURONDA,
HERE'S YOUR BEST SHOT.
THIS IS ONE OF THE RARE ONES
THAT, IN THE WIDE,
IT'S STRIKING.
THIS IS A BEAUTIFUL PHOTO
CLOSE, FAR, EVERYTHING.
AND YOU SEE HER IMMEDIATELY.
THIS IS GORGEOUS,
BUT, FURONDA, YOUR OTHER FILM...
(laughter)
AND THEN...
I TOLD THEM
MY WOMANLY SPACE IS HURTING.
IT'S EXCRUCIATING PAIN.
WELL, I SAW THE PAIN.
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT'S TIME
FOR THE JUDGES TO DELIBERATE.
AND WHEN I CALL YOU BACK,
I'LL ANNOUNCE THE FIRST GIRL
THAT HAS TO GO BACK HOME,
AND IT'S A LONG WAY BACK.
NOW IT'S TIME TO DECIDE
WHICH OF THESE GIRLS
SHOULD GO HOME.
FIRST UP IS SARA.
WELL, I THINK SARA SORTA
HAS TO GET OVER
THIS WHOLE
"I'M INTELLIGENT" THING.
'CAUSE SHE'S VERY INSECURE
IN EVERY OTHER WAY,
SO SHE THINKS THAT SHE
CAN BLIND US WITH HER BRAINS.
I THINK SARA'S TRYING.
SHE'S REALLY, REALLY,
TRYING,
AND I DO FEEL LIKE
SHE IS IMPROVING.
JADE.
I HAVE TO GIVE IT TO JADE.
SHE'S NOT REALLY
MY TYPE OF GIRL,
BUT THAT'S A GREAT PHOTOGRAPH
AND SHE REALLY TRIED TODAY.
THIS PICTURE OF JADE ACTUALLY
LOOKS SWEET IN THE FACE,
BUT JADE IS JADE.
AND SHE'S
ALWAYS GONNA BE JADE.
JADE SAYS, "DON'T
JUDGE A BOOK BY ITS COVER."
SOMETIMES THE COVER'S
MORE INTERESTING
THAT THE CONTENTS.
FURONDA.
I ACTUALLY
LOVE THIS PHOTOGRAPH AS WELL,
ALTHOUGH SHE GOT
COMPLETELY CONFUSED TODAY
WHEN YOU GAVE HER THE TASK.
WELL, I GUESS IN HER DRESS
TODAY SHE DID SHINE.
SHE TWINKLED LIKE A LITTLE STAR
THAT WE HOPE THAT SHE CAN BE.
I THINK THE LIGHT
HITS YOU DIFFERENTLY
ON THIS SIDE OF THE TABLE,
BECAUSE I'M JUST NOT
FEELING IT AT ALL.
THAT DRESS, HER SPEECH...
IT DOESN'T ADD UP FOR ME.
JOANIE.
THIS IS
MY FAVORITE PHOTOGRAPH.
I THINK SHE LOOKS SEXY
AND LIKE A MERMAID.
ABSOLUTELY GORGEOUS.
I'M STILL NOT CONVINCED
ABOUT HER IN PERSON.
THERE'S JUST THAT AWKWARDNESS.
SHE HAS CONSISTENTLY DONE
GOOD PHOTOGRAPHS, IN MY BOOK.
DANIELLE.
SHE'S PICKING HER GAME UP.
SHE'S THE ONE TO WATCH,
AND I THINK THAT THE OTHER GIRLS
NEED TO REALLY BE CAREFUL
AT THIS POINT.
SHE'S GOT A RADIANCE,
DOESN'T SHE?
SHE'S A BIT COUNTRY.
(Southern accent)
YES, SHE IS KIND OF
COUNTRY, ISN'T SHE?
OH, I LOVE THAT, YOU SEE.
(normal voice)
I DON'T THINK THERE'S ANYTHING
WRONG WITH IT
JUST AS LONG AS YOU KNOW HOW
TO TURN IT OFF.
I DON'T THINK
SHE KNOWS HOW TO TURN IT OFF.
SHE COULD LEARN.
NNENNA.
THIS IS NOT A GREAT SHOT
OF NNENNA.
SHE MANAGES TO SORT OF KEEP IT
IN THAT VERY SAFE AREA.
SHE NEEDS TO REALLY SORT OF
RAISE THE BAR, AND SHE'S NOT.
I THINK NNENNA
IS SINKING FAST.
WHENEVER I SEE THIS GIRL
STAND BEFORE ME, ALL I GET IS...
(chirping)
(laughter)
I THINK YOU GUYS
CAN'T HANDLE NNENNA.
I THINK SHE INTIMIDATES YOU.
JADE FRIGHTENS ME.
DON'T LEAVE ME IN A ROOM
WITH JADE.
(laughs)
SIX GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE FIVE PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE FIVE OF YOU THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
DANIELLE.
FUN PERSONALITY
GETS YOU A LONG WAY.
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
JADE.
CONGRATULATIONS, JADE.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU
FOR BELIEVING IN ME.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I AM GOING TO CALL...
SARA.
CONGRATULATIONS, SARA.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE NEXT NAME THAT
I'M GOING TO CALL...
JOANIE.
CONGRATULATIONS, JOANIE.
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
WILL NNENNA AND FURONDA
STEP FORWARD, PLEASE?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS,
AND THIS PHOTO REPRESENTS
THE GIRL
THAT IS STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
I WILL CALL ONLY ONE NAME.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOTEL,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
NNENNA,
YOU STARTED THIS COMPETITION
AT THE TOP OF THE PACK.
YOU HAVE THAT "IT" THING.
BUT THAT "IT" THING
IS FADING.
SOME OF THE JUDGES FEEL LIKE,
"I'M BORED.
WHAT ELSE IS SHE BRINGING
TO THE TABLE?"
FURONDA, SOME OF THE JUDGES
FROM THE START
WERE THE OPPOSITE WITH YOU.
THEY WERE LIKE,
"WHY IS SHE HERE?"
BUT THEN YOU TOOK A PHOTO
AND ANOTHER PHOTO
AND ANOTHER PHOTO,
AND CONTINUED TO IMPROVE.
BUT THE JUDGES STILL LOOK AT YOU
AND SAY, "IS SHE A MODEL?"
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL THAT STARTED
SO STRONGLY--
SOME OF THE JUDGES ARE LIKE,
"I'M KINDA BORED RIGHT NOW."
OR THE GIRL THAT STARTED WEAK
AND HAS PROGRESSED,
BUT THE JUDGES
STILL LOOK AT HER
AND DON'T NECESSARILY SEE
A MODEL IN PERSON.
AND TO BE A TOP MODEL,
YOU HAVE TO BE A TOP MODEL
IN PERSON, TOO.
SO YOU HAVE TO WORK
ON YOUR APPEARANCE, FURONDA.
NO MORE DISCO DRESSES.
KEEP IT NICE AND SIMPLE.
YOU DON'T WANNA GIVE THE JUDGES
ANY EXCUSE TO SEND YOU HOME.
AND AS I SAID BEFORE,
WHEN IT GETS THIS TIGHT,
LITTLE THINGS
JUST MAKE THEM GO, "UGH."
CONGRATULATIONS.
YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU, NNENNA.
I'M SURPRISED
I'M THE ONE GOING HOME TONIGHT,
BUT COMING INTO
THIS COMPETITION,
THERE ARE NO CERTAINTIES.
I ABSOLUTELY UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE JUDGES ARE SAYING.
PICTURES ARE IMPORTANT,
AND BEING ABLE TO GIVE
VARIATIONS AND TRANSFORM
IN EACH PHOTOGRAPH
IS CRUCIAL.
THIS EXPERIENCE
HAS MADE ME WANT IT MORE.
I WANT TO DO RUNWAY
AND SHOOT WITH
AS MANY PHOTOGRAPHERS
AS POSSIBLE.
THAT'S MY DREAM,
AND I HOPE THIS HELPS
MAKE IT MUCH EASIER TO ACHIEVE
THOSE GOALS.
♪♪♪
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
GIRL, I AIN'T--
WHY YOU GETTING UPSET?
- I'M JUST--IT'S A JOKE.
- I'M NOT GETTING UPSET.
TEMPERS FLAIR IN THAILAND
BETWEEN JADE AND JOANIE.
- YOU'RE SO DEFENSIVE, JADE.
- I AM NOT!
- THEN CHANGE ANYTHING?
- ARE YOU TYRA, JOANIE?
- I'M JUST SAYING...
- LIES.
- (singsongy) LIES!
- LISTEN TO YOURSELF.
AND ONE GIRL IS RUSHED
TO THE EMERGENCY ROOM.